การ optimization แบบ classical เป็นขั้นตอนสำคัญใน classical-quantum algorithms
อย่าง variational quantum eigensolver หรือ quantum machine learning
แต่บ่อยครั้งการหาค่าต่ำสุดของ
ฟังก์ชันที่ซับซ้อนในปริภูมิพารามิเตอร์มิติสูงนั้นทำได้ยาก
สวัสดี ฉันชื่อ Victoria Lipinska ในวิดีโอนี้เราจะมาดู
routine การ optimization แบบ classical สำหรับ classical-quantum algorithms กัน
ปัญหา optimization นั้นไม่ง่ายเลย
เมื่อจำนวนพารามิเตอร์เพิ่มขึ้น จำนวนการผสมค่าที่เป็นไปได้ก็เพิ่มขึ้นด้วย
และมันเพิ่มขึ้นแบบ exponential เลย
ในหมากรุก ตัวอย่างเช่น มีช่องทั้งหมด 64 ช่อง
แต่ละฝ่ายมีหมาก 16 ตัว หลังจากแต่ละฝ่ายเดินหมากหนึ่งครั้ง
จะมีตำแหน่งที่เป็นไปได้ 400 แบบ หลังเดินสองรอบมี 72,084 ตำแหน่ง
ประมาณ 9 ล้านหลังสามรอบ และประมาณ
2.8 แสนล้านหลังสี่รอบ
ถ้าเล่นถึงแค่ 40 รอบ จำนวนตำแหน่งที่เป็นไปได้
ประมาณว่าอยู่ที่ 10 ยกกำลัง 120
การเล่นหมากรุกได้อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบต้องสำรวจทุกตำแหน่งที่เป็นไปได้
และการขยายตัวมหาศาลแบบนี้หมายความว่าการไล่ดู
ทุกตำแหน่งทีละอันนั้นไม่มีทางทำได้จริง
แก้ได้โดยแบ่งปัญหาออกเป็นสองปัญหาย่อยที่เล็กลง
อย่างแรกคือต้องหาว่าการจัดตำแหน่งบนกระดานแบบไหน
ที่มีแนวโน้มจะเกิดขึ้นในขั้นต่อไปของเกม
เราจะเรียกสิ่งนี้ว่า subspace ที่สนใจ
อย่างที่สองคือ เมื่อรู้ subspace นั้นแล้ว ต้องหาว่าการเดินหมากใดดีที่สุด
เราจะเรียกมันว่า best move
ในการเปรียบเทียบนี้ การค้นหาใน subspace ที่สนใจในตอนแรก
คือสิ่งที่เทียบได้กับ classical optimization algorithm ของเรา
เมื่อรู้ subspace ที่สนใจแล้ว
quantum algorithm มักจะเป็นตัวที่รับผิดชอบในการหา best move
โดยใช้ข้อมูลจาก subspace นั้น
เริ่มจากพิจารณาพารามิเตอร์แค่ตัวเดียวก่อน
คือ theta ซึ่งเป็นพารามิเตอร์ของ cost function ที่เราต้องการ optimize
ถ้าวาดกราฟฟังก์ชันนี้ มันจะมีหน้าตาประมาณนี้
แกน X แทนค่าของพารามิเตอร์ theta
และแกน Y แทนค่า cost function
อย่าลืมว่า cost function อาจเป็นต้นทุนทางการเงินจริงๆ ที่เราต้องการลดให้ต่ำลง
หรืออย่างที่มักพบใน variational quantum
eigensolver มันอาจเป็นพลังงานที่ธรรมชาติพยายามลดลงเอง
เป้าหมายของเราคือหาค่า theta
ที่ทำให้ cost ต่ำที่สุด
เริ่มจากค่าเริ่มต้นของ theta และในแต่ละขั้นตอน optimization
เราหา theta ใหม่ที่ทำให้ cost ลดลงไปอีก
ดูเหมือนง่ายที่จะรู้ว่าควรไปทางไหนบนกราฟถ้ามองเห็นภาพรวม
แต่ความยากของการ optimization คือเรามองไม่เห็นภาพนั้น
เราได้รู้แค่ค่า cost ซึ่งเป็นแค่ชิ้นเล็กๆ ของภาพทั้งหมด
เมื่อเราคำนวณฟังก์ชันที่ค่า theta ที่เลือกไว้เท่านั้น
นี่คือหลักการทั่วไปของการ optimization
optimizer จะสุ่มค่าพารามิเตอร์ theta แล้วคำนวณ cost
อย่างที่คิดออก การเลือก theta แบบสุ่มเพื่อสร้างภาพ topology
ของฟังก์ชันทั้งหมดนั้นไม่ได้มีประสิทธิภาพเลย
แทนที่จะทำอย่างนั้น optimizer ที่ฉลาดจะคำนวณ
gradient ของฟังก์ชันในแต่ละขั้นตอน
ด้วยวิธีนี้ optimizer จะรู้ว่าควรไปทิศทางใดบนกราฟ
เพื่อหาค่า cost ที่น้อยที่สุด
เมื่อ gradient เป็นศูนย์ algorithm จะหยุดทำงาน
และพบค่าต่ำสุดแล้ว
แต่ค่าต่ำสุดนี้อาจไม่ใช่ค่าต่ำสุดสากล
อาจเป็นแค่ค่าต่ำสุดเฉพาะที่
หมายความว่ามันเป็นค่าที่น้อยที่สุดในบริเวณใกล้เคียง
แต่ไม่ใช่ค่าต่ำสุดตลอดทั้งช่วงของ theta
ในกรณีที่มีพารามิเตอร์ตัวเดียว สิ่งนี้อาจเกิดขึ้นได้
แต่ยิ่งมีพารามิเตอร์มากเท่าไหร่
ฟังก์ชันก็ยิ่งซับซ้อนมากขึ้นเท่านั้น
แค่สองพารามิเตอร์ก็กลายเป็น surface แล้ว
พอถึงสี่พารามิเตอร์ก็วาดภาพไม่ได้อีกต่อไป
เหมือนตัวอย่างหมากรุก การแจกแจงทุกความเป็นไปได้
ก็กลายเป็นสิ่งที่ทำไม่ได้อย่างรวดเร็ว
จะเห็นว่าการหาค่าต่ำสุดของ
ฟังก์ชันที่ซับซ้อนในปริภูมิพารามิเตอร์มิติสูงนั้นยากมาก
แต่เพื่อให้ได้ผลลัพธ์ที่ดี เราต้องการให้ classical optimization
ทั้งเร็วและแม่นยำ
นอกจากนี้ยังต้องทนต่อ noise ได้ด้วย
ซึ่งจะมีผลกระทบอย่างมากกับ quantum computers ในยุคใกล้นี้
Classical optimization algorithms แบ่งออกได้กว้างๆ
เป็นสองประเภท ได้แก่ direct search และ gradient based methods
Gradient based methods ต้องใช้ข้อมูล gradient
ของฟังก์ชันระหว่างกระบวนการ optimization
ซึ่งคำนวณได้ทั้งแบบ analytical
หรือประมาณค่าด้วย finite difference calculation
Direct search methods ไม่ใช้ข้อมูล gradient
แต่ใช้กลยุทธ์อื่นเพื่อหาค่าต่ำสุดของ cost function
optimization algorithms ที่ใช้กันบ่อยที่สุด
ในวงการ quantum computing มีดังต่อไปนี้
COBYLA ย่อมาจาก constrained optimization by linear approximation
และเป็น optimization algorithm แบบไม่ใช้ gradient
SLSQP คือ sequential least squares programming
ซึ่งเป็น optimization algorithm แบบใช้ gradient
มันใช้ stochastic perturbation vector
เพื่อคำนวณ gradient โดยประมาณของ cost function พร้อมกัน
ในสภาพแวดล้อมที่ไม่มี noise พบว่า optimizer อย่าง COBYLA
และ SLSQP converge ได้เร็วกว่า SPSA
Classical optimizers มีพารามิเตอร์ของตัวเอง
ที่กำหนดได้สำหรับแต่ละกรณี เช่น step size
โดยทั่วไปหาได้จาก documentation ที่เกี่ยวข้อง
กับ optimizer นั้นๆ
แนะนำให้ดูรายการ references ด้านล่างสำหรับการเปรียบเทียบ
classical optimizers ที่อัปเดตที่สุด
มาดูปรากฏการณ์อีกอย่างที่เกี่ยวข้องกัน
กับการ optimize circuit ควอนตัมแบบ parameterized กัน
อย่างที่เห็นก่อนหน้านี้ gradient ที่หายไปของ cost function อาจบ่งบอกว่า
optimizer ติดอยู่บนที่ราบแบน ไม่มีลักษณะน่าสนใจ ที่เรียกว่า
"barren plateau"
barren plateau เกิดได้จากหลายปัจจัย
gradient ของ cost function ที่สอดคล้องกับ circuit ควอนตัม
ที่มีการกำหนดพารามิเตอร์เริ่มต้นแบบสุ่ม
จะลดลงสู่ศูนย์แบบ exponential ตามจำนวน qubit
เพราะว่าปริภูมิควอนตัมที่ optimizer สำรวจ
จะขยายใหญ่แบบ exponential เมื่อจำนวน qubit เพิ่มขึ้น
วิธีรับมือปัญหานี้รวมถึงการลดจำนวนพารามิเตอร์
และด้วยเหตุนั้นจึงลดมิติของปริภูมิพื้นฐานด้วย
อีกมุมมองหนึ่งของต้นเหตุปัญหา barren plateau
อาจมาจากลักษณะที่ parameterized circuit ไม่ได้ถูกออกแบบมาสำหรับปัญหาใดเป็นพิเศษ
เมื่อเผชิญกับปริภูมิพารามิเตอร์ที่ใหญ่แบบ exponential
การออกแบบ circuit ให้เหมาะสมกับ
ปัญหาที่กำลังพิจารณาอาจเป็นแนวทางแก้ไขที่ดี
นอกจากปริภูมิพารามิเตอร์แบบ exponential ที่ทำให้เกิด barren plateaus แล้ว
ปรากฏการณ์ทางฟิสิกส์อื่นๆ ก็สามารถก่อให้เกิดได้เช่นกัน ได้แก่
noise และ decoherence ที่เกิดขึ้นในการทดลอง quantum computing
ความสามารถในการแสดงออกโดยรวมของ parameterized circuit
หรือ nonlocality และระดับของ entanglement ของ cost function ที่สร้างแบบจำลอง
ยังคงเป็นพื้นที่การวิจัยที่ยังเปิดอยู่เพื่อรับมือกับความท้าทายเหล่านี้
ตอนนี้ที่ได้ทบทวนองค์ประกอบหลักของ VQE แล้ว
เราจะสรุป algorithm ในวิดีโอถัดไป